was right about the tuck rule all those
years who's right now about fumbling
through the end zone
definitely not being the rule
it should be you know knows that more
than anybody else
mike pereira former head of nfl refs now
nfl on fox
rules analyst how are you mike you know
i'm really
i'm really good but i'm looking through
all the proposals
that the the cut that the owners are
going to discuss
and i'm looking at you know remove the
on-field video
review from the replay process uh make
all
uh illegal forward passes loss of down
yeah
um all of these things it's funny i
don't see anything about a fumble
forward into the end zone yes
now mike mike you're you're you're now
cherry-picking which
information to give us and i'm not
accusing you
of of wrongfully saying that this is not
up for
review um you know the way this works
you've been in the competition committee
room you
know how it works you know that teams
understand what would even remotely
become close to passing muster or not
you
know whether it's ready to be put in
front of ownership now or not
you know how this works and they just
don't feel that
it's ready they don't have the proper
wording or ruling or even
maybe consensus in the room but i think
you and i both know it's coming
we know it's coming mike we know it
right i'll grant you
we did say that about the tuck crew you
did say that about the touch rule so
i will i will give you that and there's
always something to me that like
reflects eisen when you look at all
these
proposals isaac it's like if you if you
if you put like in front of me
a plan about overtime and the toss and
if you put in front of me pick and
choose
and you said who would have proposed
something like that
i would have said rich that's right more
than john harbaugh to tell you the truth
exactly mike and by the way who also
came up to you
at the owner's meeting years ago i
believe it was in tampa florida
where uh you know they were changing the
rules on celebration and you were right
you were rightfully saying that you had
a as the head of nfl refs the number of
letters you got from high school and pop
warner coaches saying you need to fix
this in the pros because we're seeing it
too much here they're looking at the
pros
but who told you that it was too
stringent in that there would be some
sort of reversal of this rule on
celebrations who told you that back then
mike
who is the one to tell you that would
that that would be
that would be you that would be you so
i'm just saying
i am a seer i'm an understander
of the room i read the temperature i
take the figurative pulse
tell me this pylon rule's never going to
be changed tell me that mike prayer tell
me
tell me that again the the pylon rule
yes it's a it's a it's a it's a
wonderful rule it's
it's easily understandable now you know
if you're in bounds and go into the end
zone then that goal line extends if
you're not you got to get the ball over
the pileup
before you touch out of bounds it's a
beautiful rule
but there are a lot bigger issues in the
game than the fumbling
no i know that i i get the fumbling
through the end zone at half
i hear that from you uh i've heard that
from all your successors
at the job that it's that it basically
it happens what five
ten times a year it just happens always
in a nationally televised game and it's
gonna happen
in a super bowl mic and the whole
country is gonna say
what the hell was that and then
we're really gonna have a mess on our
hands i guarantee you
this will happen if we don't fix this
rule and my rule change would be
you fumble through the end zone reverse
touch back keep the same down
same down so if you fumble on third down
you you
it's it's a loss of down but back at the
20 yard line so at least somebody's got
a chance to kick a a field goal from the
20-yard line on fourth down if it
happens on first down and yeah
too bad it's first and goal it's now
second in goal from the 20-yard line
what's wrong with that
you keep possession what's wrong with
that nothing nothing's wrong with that
but
again you know i'm like all my
successors or the guys that followed me
the whole ball of wax
of the guys before me when you fumbled
the ball
into your opponent's end zone to me it's
worse than fumbling the ball forward
out of bounds that's just the way i feel
about that
and i i hate this thought of i don't
hate the thought because it's you
but i hate the thought of you know
fumbling forward out of bounds and now
you take the ball that was snapped at
the three and fumbled at the two and put
it at the 20.
um you know to me you got to play
football and to me hold on the ball you
want to stretch to
stretch your arm out stretch your hand
to try to get into the end zone
and and risk losing control of the ball
that's your risk but to me i i don't i
don't think that's
that's part of the major problems that
we have in the
in officiating in rules today mike
pereira here on the rich eisen show what
are the major problems in officiating in
rules today that you think needs to be
fixed
well i think when you look at what's
being talked about you know the the
addition of uh
of a booth official however you want to
call it i think that's the biggest
possible step to improve officiating on
the field
i don't like the way that i'm hearing
that it's being presented which is
unlike what baltimore presented which is
an eighth official
who has access to video who is off the
field and who can contribute in real
time
to the crew um i like that call it the
sky
judge it has been tried before um in the
aaf the um whatever it was and the xfl
it's doable it can correct egregious
errors it can be
limited um to personal fouls player
safety issues
and for like pass interference inside of
let's say five minutes of the fourth
quarter but to me
what they're talking about is giving the
replay official more responsibility
to me opens up a lot of problems um
and and i i think the replay official
has enough to do
right now and i i think the the key to
me is an eighth official just rules on
things that are
outside of replay not not
not the inside of replay stuff on what's
a catch and what's not a catch
you know did he step on the line did he
not you're talking about was that a face
mask
was it roughing the passer was it a hit
on a on an illegal hit on a receiver
those types of player safety things
which to me
can be done officially efficiently
i don't believe it will extend uh the
length of games by
a whole lot um and and again it has to
be limited
not not not looking at whether
something's a delayed game about what
the play clock ran out or whether the
right guard
farts fault started um you know just the
big
issue plays and and and i think if our
goal is to get better and our
goal is not to have missed calls then
i think that's the answer but not
the replay official trying to decide
quickly whether something's a catch or
not a catch and
correct it and not go to review and then
the poor coaches on the sidelines and
their guys upstairs
well they're going to wait to see is
replay going to change this immediately
or we're going to do it do we
it's fraught with problems so i i think
that's
one of the big issues that that will be
actually decided upon because
i do think something will happen so yeah
the you're you're hearing that
they're gonna try and um just add more
responsibilities to a replay official as
opposed to add someone else
and the the verbiage i'm hearing
is that this uh replay official that
would have expanded responsibilities as
a de facto sky
judge would be involved in subjective
issues that's the words that i'm hearing
or that could be
utilized as a as a codification as as a
an actual rule that's put in there what
what what do you think that would be do
you think do you think this has a chance
of passing
well i think certainly there's a chance
that something is gonna pass and i'm
hearing more of the expansion of the
replay official look
um you're not gonna go to a sky judge or
an eighth official
unless you get the total support of the
officiating department
um if i was still running the department
i would be
in the committee meeting saying this is
what i want to do
um and and so i i look at this whole
thing of being subjected with the replay
official
look the replay official doesn't even
make any decisions now
all decisions are made in new york so if
he's going to be
something he's got to make a subjective
decision are we going to wait for new
york to make that subjective decision
it's it's like wait a minute where where
where is the process here where's the
process and so
you know i look at this and saying
you're going to expand the duties of the
replay official who in many cases hasn't
even worked a game of football or
hasn't certainly worked in the nfl are
we going to give them
this responsibility or does poor al
river on get more responsibility in new
york
there's no way that new york they're
going to see every repping the passer
hit for example
and make a decision on whether uh it's
it's a correct call or one that should
have been called or one that's
incorrect i mean it's it's just it's
there's too many layers there
and and i just think that the the issue
of an
eighth official and and while i like
john harbaugh's and baltimore's you know
uh proposal
i don't feel like they went far enough i
mean there has to be you can't just say
this is what we ought to do um how can
we do it
and to me how could we get an eighth
official and
who is this eighth official and if it's
me i'd say hey
we're going to bring in 18 new officials
and each crew is going to be an
eight-member crew
and we're going to rotate we're going to
rotate let's not tunnel vision everybody
that
this is your position this is the only
one you can work take the three deep
officials and move them every fourth
game into this uh
into the booth um i think it would
improve officiating it would get more
officials into the program
and get them started so um i i just
i i we always seen and i was the same
we try to make things better by putting
band-aids on things
and on problems or on sores or on
scrapes
when the big way to really make a big
difference to me
and and what we refuse to talk about
with any great
length is full-time officials do
referees need to be full-time which i
certainly believe they do the the 17
referees
100 full-time working every day of the
football
season under one roof during the week
and
then again this eighth official using
real time
it happens now you see a block in the
back
called and then all of a sudden the
officials get together and they pick up
the flag
you see a face mask called the officials
get together
and they pick up the flag because
another official has another view
here's the eighth official with another
view that he gets the luxury of seeing
the
live shot and run it back and forth and
a quick replay and if they can get it
within a 15 second time frame within 15
seconds
left on the play clock if they can get
it done before that then make the change
it'll look
funny but you know what replay looked
funny when we brought it in but
everybody got used to it well it would
be the same here
mike i was at mike pereira here uh on
the rich house show as you know i was
there for the owners meeting where it
was ruled as permanent and i remember
charlie cashely of the texans
organization at the time
and he was in the competition committee
he told the owners everybody has replay
at home
everybody's got it in high definition if
we don't use it
uh you know everyone else is seeing it
so it yeah you know that's why i'm
always been an advocate of replay and so
but you know how this works uh
it's everything needs to be done
incrementally because there's so many
people that just can't wrap their heads
around
such a radical change and then there
there's also some other
aspects of moving things back to where
they once were there's a certain
uh uh part of of nfl membership that
just
thinks that we're you know anything
that's changing from the old way of
doing it or the the
if you will uh long-time way of doing it
is
is something that they they have a
problem with uh
why am i hearing that overtime rules
need to go back to what it was we're
just like let's flip the coin and
somebody goes
you know uh six plays kicks a field goal
and we're done
why why am i hearing that where did that
come from i
i don't know and i don't agree with that
at all i mean i
i i agree with what we got to there are
certain people that think it should go
further than that and that even on a
touchdown that the other team should get
an
opportunity but i think it was a i think
that was a
a good you know a good change and i
think it's good the way it is again
i'd move beyond that and say where's our
issue
here when we look at the on-site kick
situation
you know to me you you look at that and
say here's some startling numbers i mean
the success rate on on-site kicks from
2010 to 17 was 13 and a half percent
and from 2000 to 1818 through 2020
it was excuse me 7.8
and 2020 alone it was 4.8
and then the the whole notion of if you
go back and look at this how about this
that between the two minute warning and
three minutes remaining in the fourth
quarter
a team that was down one to eight points
attempted on side kicks
42.1 of the time
in 2020 8.3
of the time well that's a player safety
issue isn't it mike because of the way
that you're allowed to line up
for kickoff that that that's i think
it's not
yeah it's not just lining up and of
course it's a player safety issue i get
it
but it's the restriction on being able
to advance right so you
have to be flat-footed basically when
the ball is kicked
and that's probably the biggest limiting
thing to me
and so i have to look at that it's time
to look at that what's the sense
of this whole fourth and fifteen on side
kick alternative i think is a good one
and so what what if you could wave a
wand and make that happen
what would that look like to you well it
would be
it would be very simple after you score
a touchdown the team would be
given the opportunity to say do you want
to kick off do you want it on side
and if you're going onside it's a fourth
and 15 attempt so we play football
you snap the ball to 25 and you play
it's fourth
and 15. if you get it to the 40 on the
play
guess what you keep the ball and
continue playing um if you have
fouls on the play yeah we play it just
like a fourth and 15. so
you don't make it to the 40-yard line
but
uh the defense is offside then you get
another down and it's fourth and ten
from the 30. what if there's a what if
there's a hole
yeah yeah what if there's an automatic
first down or or passing through
you get it if there's an automatic first
down you play on
so you just basically play fourth and
15. now the danger
i think is the straight play that is
unsuccessful so you throw the pass and
it's
incomplete boy now the other team gets
the ball first antenna to 25
now that's that's almost a gimme for
another score where at least in the
traditional on-site kick thing if you
kick them to 35
the other team is probably going to get
the ball to 45
but now they're going to get it excuse
me at the 25.
so that's a big difference but you're
gonna have to do
something to i think make it a better
opportunity for the team to to come back
in the game now fourth and 15
on itself boy the success rate's not
very good on just a straight play
without penalty or anything it's about
two and a half percent
but with penalties and everything it
certainly increases but
i i think there has to be an alternative
and i think there's been
enough research done that i do think
it'd be
more of an exciting play for people to
watch
and um and again it brings in the whole
notion of the penalty situation
which uh you know which just makes a
play like football
mike you the man let's chat uh let's
chat in the next couple weeks when we
know exactly what's
been done and what you you think the
unintended consequences of the proper
consequences are let's do that again
soon
okay busy time thank you you're the man
that's mike pereira
chief rules analyst on fox
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here